[Music]
in this episode we're going to talk
about America's favorite vegetable at
least to grow in their garden and that's
the Tomato tomatoes are going to have to
be planted after the last frost they do
not tolerate Frost and they really like
warm soil and air temperatures the
tomato is Gardener's favorite vegetable
to grow for several reasons first off
they're just downright good to eat they
go with many different things in many
different ways there are literally
hundreds of different varieties of
tomatoes there's yellow ones there's red
ones and everything in between it's
great to can tomatoes and use them all
year long one thing to really remember
about tomatoes is they're going to use a
lot of water tomatoes need to be watered
deep and they need to be watered pretty
often more often than most other things
and in many places in Wyoming in order
to get a tomato you're going to have to
either start the seed inside or buy
pretty big bedding plants when you when
you go to plant your garden when we uh
talk about how productive the tomato is
you can see here these tomato plants
have cages around them um these tomatoes
are going to grow up and these these
cages are going to support them because
there's going to be hopefully so many
tomatoes on there that will need that
support of course in my family it's just
hasn't been summer until we pick a pick
a tomato off the vine warm eat it like
an apple with a little bit of juice
running down our face this is Hudson
Hill with the University volum extension
you're watching from the ground up
[Music]